it was the perfect one yeah i don't know
what happened
oh
[Music]
what's up everybody today we have a
guest in our house we usually bake with
this guest uh this guest has been on jk
with us before and she's a sister to me
and is none other than
julia
i am back we're here to make more egg
darts yes we are me and julia we've been
obsessed with making egg tarts i just
why do we why why are we making egg
tarts just trying to get closer to our
kanto roots i think so yeah like we just
started doing it and we're like we got
to keep we got to keep perfecting we got
to perfect it honestly like james bakery
in monterey park was the one that made
me be like man i really like those egg
tarts are well if you guys haven't been
there you guys should definitely try it
try their like the portuguese egg tart
which is like the potats and then the uh
the regular egg which is their hong kong
style one you should definitely try it
and you'll know what i mean and then
ever since that day i've just been
obsessed like i want to know like
can egg tarts be easily made and can i
make them really delicious just like
gyms and what have we found so far
we suck at veggies
they're ridiculously hard to make
they're literally handcrafted like i've
been searching like is there a machine
that pumps like the crust out like into
the shape and the mold no they're all
just handcrafted you have to like press
it into the well there is a mold but you
you press it with your thumbs and
there's no actual like machine that
presses it into the mold so yeah or
maybe there is and we have no idea
true maybe there is there's some top
secret like uh hong kong chef that's
like no i got the secret just not
telling you there's like the ancient
chinese way so we got this started
[Music]
all right so it's been a while since we
made egg tarts so we
last all of quarantine basically of 2020
we were obsessed with making egg tarts
and i think we got pretty good at one
point but now it's been
half a year since the last time we met
up to make egg tarts i've forgotten
everything i was just like we're
supposed to mix the butter in the dough
and then casey was like no no no we
gotta roll out the dough and then we
like spread the butter on it and fold it
in and i was like oh yeah yeah you right
and then i'm just thinking wow this is
really sticky was it always the sticky
yeah i think so i don't remember any of
this yeah it's one of those uh doughs
where like it literally sticks to the
table top and you got to use the the
flour
yeah you have to scrape it off and then
and it melts on you because this this
butter needs to be room temp but then
the more you touch it with your hands
your body temperature it melts the
butter even more
yeah so it's a it's a messy business
making egg tarts why did we sign up for
this i don't know why we like the way it
tastes and we like the the mouth feel
mouth feel is so important the texture
of the nectar the flaky crust and then
the nice creamy custard in the middle
and the satisfaction that you made it
the satisfaction that we made it exactly
so we only tried the matcha flavor once
we actually vlogged it last time but we
added too much matcha so today we're
gonna lessen the matcha we're gonna see
if uh we can find that proper matcha
amount to add into the egg tart so we're
gonna do matcha today we're gonna do the
uh traditional portuguese style one and
we're also maybe thinking about making
the hong kong one yeah with the
different crusts with the cookie crust
like i'm so hungry right now for sweets
and i don't know i never crave sweets
and i'm like so weird i have it in my
head to like i just want to i want to
eat um you know what i've been craving
to lately is a
low ball bang
a wife wife biscuit wife like what do
you call that wife biscuit english yeah
the traditional chinese bakery item it's
made out of winter melon as a filling
and it's so good and i've been craving
that like crazy recently
and also a nice glass of hong kong milk
tea i've been craving you know what
today we're gonna do egg tarts
and
upon julia's request
i bought i bought some condensed milk
and some evaporated milk so you already
know what i'm about to do with that that
is about to become part of this
making hong kong milk tea let me okay
let me tell you guys something all right
all right telling me so
casey for all the years i've known him
um he is like a hong kong tea
connoisseur because he always likes to
try out different hong kong meal teas
and he has like different opinions for
each one of them and i was like i'm
wondering what is casey's like perfect
cup of hong kong milky and he always
talks about every single time i come
here and i'm like well where is it where
is it bro oh snap the pressure's on
so you're expecting the perfect cup of
hong kong healthy for me i'm expecting
what your taste of hong kong looks like
gotcha because like i found some places
that i like yeah but you know you were
like
i kind of wanted more like this and i
was like all right all right mr hong
kong milk tea connoisseur you show me
you show me what makes a good hong kong
milk tea all right well the pressure's
on to impress julia today don't mess up
casey don't mess up here are the
ingredients well these are for later
it's actually close to teres leches with
dos leches dos leches hong kong milk tea
so
a lot of milk teas usually use
a blend of black teas so for me today
i'm gonna use some ceylon
i'm gonna use some kimon and assam
and the big difference the big key to
making hong kong milk tea is to not
steep in hot water but to boil in hot
water for about two to three minutes
that's the big key so a lot of you know
english style teas
just simply put it in hot water you
don't want to like get that sour taste
in hong kong milk tea though we're like
get that sour taste get that crazy tea
flavor wait is it sour or is it bitter
bitter i think there's a there's a
there's a note of sourness uh when you
boil it like if you just drink it like
without the milk yeah it tastes sour to
me kind of like how like a
coffee black coffee is like their coffee
is bitter right but there's an aroma to
it and then sometimes there's like notes
of like citrus like notes of like
sourness especially blue bottle blue
bottle has like that sour coffee
so to me this is kind of like that too
where it's like there's like notes of
like just
sharp it's a sharp flavor how about that
we won't say sour
see see what i'm saying connoisseur no
no no no i'm just really picky i guess
really really picky with my hong kong
multi alright so we have our
water boiling
and now we add our tea leaves
we're gonna add a lot
one
two
that's enough for that one so this i'm
making just enough for two glasses
two cups and then we do the other one
another mix
i'm gonna smell it
too
[Music]
all right we're gonna let that boil for
two to three minutes yo that smells so
good it smells good right oh my god what
kind of blend is this uh what's this
ceylon
assam
so these are like indian um teas from
india and then this is the chinese tea
chinese
only you guys are here it just smells so
fragrant like yeah because otherwise you
don't you don't get this like aroma if
you're just steeping it like if you just
pour hot water in like like tea is very
it's very light yeah i mean i definitely
smell like black tea which is kind of
really hard to explain to you it's not
really floral like a jasmine
green tea it's like
very dark
man oh that's for the egg our dough is
done so i gotta roll it out of the
all house so once it is finished boiling
restrain it
[Music]
look at that dark black tea
[Music]
spilling oh it's broken that's why it's
spilling dang it this is stupid
try to break pour fast here we
spoon full of go
goes in there another spoon full
of this goes
[Music]
all right so how's the uh
i don't remember any of these things
like the butter just came out and i
don't know this is right or if i'm maybe
like not rolling it it happened to us
last time too it did yeah it would just
pop out oh well i'm just gonna keep
rolling until we fold in all this butter
and then we chill all right well to feel
you through the journey of making egg
tarts i present to you my hong kong milk
tea i hope it's not too watery actually
i smell the coconut milk yeah condensed
milk evaporated milk tea
oh
really i mean let me drink it is that
this is what you mean i haven't tried it
yet
it's um it's surprisingly light
it is light i could have boiled it
longer yeah it's very light is this how
you is this how you like your hong kong
teeth the sugar ratio yes is how i like
it is that a lot of places serve it too
sweet for me yeah and i kind of like the
less sweet and i want to preserve the
tea flavor like less of a dessert
but i could have gone way more on the
tea flavor should have boiled it for
like
four minutes also i think a lot of uh
really good places they get really good
teas i'm just buying teas off of amazon
i think there's a limit to how good the
amazon teas can do if you actually know
your vendor you're getting like some
like grade a asian teas i'm sure their
aroma is going to be
through the roof
all right so one of the things that we
had to discover
over the course of last year was cooking
the custard like this yeah just slightly
slightly just a little bit before we
actually bake it yeah before you bake
the custard you have to pre-cook it and
slightly thicken it through the cooking
process of double boiling so i have hot
water in there boiling in this in the
bigger pot and we put the smaller pot
into the boiling water to softly and
gently cook a custard here now we want
to avoid the scrambled egg possibility
so we have to keep stirring it and once
it starts thickening we take it off the
heat yeah
all right and while they are cooking
we have a guest here it's antoine hello
everybody this is i think this is the
very first time you might be featured
i've been here virtually no no featured
in a vlog oh yeah yeah
oh yeah at least you know the first time
in the house i was like i've been in
here so yeah virtually it's true yeah so
in case you guys didn't know antoine was
our editor well he's not like not
anymore it's just that we haven't given
him any projects or something
but that's michael too
yeah but he
he was editing a lot of our vlogs before
and then we slowed down our own
productions
because casey really wanted to start
editing again he was like i kind of miss
it so then we're like okay we'll give
antoine like different projects we just
haven't gotten around to it so you know
it's so freaking cool about antoine you
guys he actually has his own
book series like young adult young adult
but not veronica
i am just not it's not for kids it's a
it's called fiction i always get
non-fiction
yeah digitally fantasy exactly
so what what tell me what's the name of
your book promote it
well the one that is like the main one
right now is the younger one that you
mentioned which
the gatekeeper staff which is based on
west african mythology that is so
freaking like my ancestry yeah
i absolutely love that because we always
have to be proud of our culture you know
and like and also preserve that and
pass it on so i freaking love that issac
isaac
yeah
you want to come down and say hello to
people i'm in the middle okay uh guys or
i guess when you're done big old gamer
kid
cute that's just so cute i'm such a mom
about it oh cute
this is so exciting because we actually
haven't had
antoine physically visit we haven't even
seen him in like over a year like since
before the pandemic started so it's been
really cool to like have a little
reunion
also ryan's heading over so we're gonna
get to see him and he's an editor at jk2
and he also like jk news tech i haven't
seen him in a while because i haven't
been into the office in a long time so
yeah this is fun having everyone
look at this here his voice
like that
it's not even the same voice i know even
three months ago
even his little chuckle he said try it
yeah dude what happened who told you who
gave you permission to grow uh you
it's almost like you're like putting on
the voice but it's not that's just you
now this is gonna be isaac for like the
rest of the day yep
oh yeah you see no no it's a mustache
you gotta call it a mustache it's a
mustache no i had it too like right
before high school had peace but like a
long time my mom said i was born with
because oh
[Applause]
yeah look at this
can we can we get a close-up on the
mustache look at that look at that peach
fuzz
all right so we're also gonna do a
matcha
uh egg tart batch so we got our uh
second batch of egg custard we're gonna
add some mosh to it
huh sure what the last time you guys did
we're in the present and we're going
towards the future you're right you're
right i like that right i want to switch
my mentality
what was your criticism what was it it
wasn't just mine there were other people
in the room oh really
do you not remember that it wasn't as
good
to defend ourselves i guess we put too
much matcha we kind of know what were we
messed up matcha is like such high
quality that doesn't have that like
bitter matcha taste but then i think
maybe you guys were going after the
color or something yes we were cooking
with our eyes and not so much from a
culinary perspective but i i also
remember casey was like i like caffeine
true oh do you hear that yes i have a
problem right here that's why i don't
drink caffeine anymore no more coffee no
more tea just today i'm doing some hong
kong milk tea a little bit of matcha but
normally no no caffeine but that's how
it all starts
true tomorrow i'm gonna feel it and
tomorrow i'm gonna be craving more for
more and i'm gonna have to go through
the withdrawal process again
so this is one scoop
is it it doesn't look like much right
doesn't it compel you to do another
scoop
i guess so
like well that's it right no no no no no
no no no
we'll just do one we'll just do one
we're not crazy yeah well i don't know
it wouldn't seem like much
[Music]
oh that's
why maybe it was the color
oh my god that's funny
oh no no do you remember though when you
guys baked it it looked like more black
than green so maybe the color comes out
whoa
we're not we're not gonna we're not here
to talk about the past right now no
no no juliet you need to know where you
came from to know where you're going oh
true true true so
you know past experiences do help to
know the present
true really think the color might come
out more when you make it it looks
slightly if we hm it does look more
green but just very slightly the tint
change it's not like an actual
like we didn't we put a
filmmaking terms we tinted it we didn't
put a party filter on
like
we gotta put a party filter on and make
it super green do you want to add a
little bit more about one more one more
okay three we'll go into okay if it
doesn't do it then like with the one
more scoop then right right
because we're not gonna have green egg
tarts
wow
okay that's a good grain yeah that's a
good green that's great that's a good
grain oh yeah
oh
check out uh the link in the description
use our code tooth case for 10
there you go this is beautiful is it
green yeah
definitely if we compare it to our
custard our first batch of custard
it's good it's a good color
[Music]
oh that looks so good
[Music]
beautiful this looks cute dude
yeah you can tell these are green yeah
yeah these are the matcha ones yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah by the way
i know look at that beautiful camera
look at that beautiful man
so ryan had a show off his new camera
because he heard i had i got a new fx3
so what is this like a camera measuring
contest uh pretty much
here we go oven is opening
mucho caliente
nice please cook well
all right
look at this
we got some matcha egg tarts we got some
classic uh egg tart
[Music]
slightly under burnt if you want it more
burnt right yeah but it actually looks
really cooked like
yeah i'm afraid it might be like really
um
not like a smooth texture but like a
fluffy texture a scrambled egg texture
custards are a little tricky in the last
video we made about egg tarts we
undercooked the macho ones because
well we undercooked it this time to
compensate for the undercooked egg tarts
we might have overcooked it because you
don't want that at the start of like
scrambled eggs honestly i felt like the
first time we made it ever was the best
time it was the best it was the perfect
one yeah i don't know what happened
oh
oh
just scoop it back in
it tastes the same it was like a little
overcooked yeah
scrambled eggs
oh
i think we maybe overcooked the custard
prior to baking yeah
we'll see we'll see all right so we
made six egg tarts and we decided that
we should go one more round and do
another six maybe uh we're gonna make
another batch of custard because we have
extra dough so we're gonna do another
flavor a third flavor guess what flavor
we're doing well we were drinking a
flavor earlier today so we figured why
not bring that flavor into the egg cart
that we're making so we're going to do
hong kong milk tea flavored egg tarts so
i made a concentrate
of
tea here going to add some condensed
milk to this and we're gonna add all
that
into the bathtub we'll see how it goes
look at that hong kong milk tea in the
oven
bam
let's see what we got
oh
that looks really good wow
[Music]
what do you think that looks really good
another five minutes i think we're good
you think so yeah
okay
[Music]
what do you think
sounds really satisfying it does sound
good
yeah
not bad okay okay
dig in everybody i think there's one for
everyone uh one of each flavor for
everyone
right and very slight but still tastes
like pretty egg custardy
i've been figuring this for so long yeah
yeah isaac's a fan of my homemade egg
tarts even the bad ones the deformed and
ugly ones you're like those are bomb i'm
your ultimate supporter thank you
oh no club yeah can i have a bite
like it has a nice the vanilla really
came through pat ryan what do you guys
think really good you like it
did the magic come through in your
opinion i'm still eating it
he's like let me enjoy it i just gotta
know okay this is the hong kong milk tea
oh wait i am missing you on this tasting
test oh yeah grab a plate oh i've seen
i've seen bites not three all right
[Music]
but the milk cheese is aggressive okay
okay let me try this
one perfect
professional flaky okay you know the
milk tube doesn't taste that sweet
yeah it doesn't it's got that like
slight bitter edge to it
what do you think
i feel like it still tastes a little
eggy
but it's not as sweet i taste the cheese
yeah i didn't know and then you guys
said
this like the custard it's so
custardy
this one's good yeah
i like the milk tea one i don't i don't
think it's as strong as you guys are
saying yeah
i don't know it's the strongest flavor
out of the three interesting
i can't i can't taste the matcha
personally yeah i can't use the matcha
either
[Music]
you